[Musica]
non futures for science of contamination
non c'è futuro per la scienza senza
contaminazione e per iniziare questo
messaggio voglio partire da un esempio
da un esempio mutuato dalla biologia ed
all'agricoltura contamination al cross
fertilization sono due termini che
derivano dalla biologia e che indicano
come noi possiamo mettere assieme i
caratteri genetici di due individui
diversi per generare un nuovo individuo
migliore più forte più resistente
all'ambiente esterno più capace di
sopravvivere in condizioni estreme
qualcosa che i nostri agricoltori il
agricoltori di tutto il mondo hanno
sempre fatto facendo gli innesti creando
nuovi ceppi genetici di piante capaci di
vivere in condizioni estreme
migliaia di anni prima l'invenzione
della biologia molecolare e del dna
ricombinante ora inizio con un esempio
un po provocatorio la pianta della can
la pianta della coca eric tops il un
cocker in un inizio da questo per
stimolare delle abitudini diciamo un po
discutibili ma perché questo è un
esempio virtuoso di quello che voglio
dirvi ora i coltivatori della bolivia e
del perù da anni selezionano le piante
di coca migliorie come fanno ogni anno
alla fine della stagione loro non
accolgono la piantina rimasta nella zona
più buia della compagna in cui coltivano
nella zona dove non arriva mai la luce
del sole nella zona battuta dal vento
più esposta alle intemperie dove il 99,9
per cento delle piantine muore ma
quell'unica piantina che sopravvive è la
più resistente di tutti e loro la
prendono e la portano subito ad un
livello di altitudine superiore di nuovo
la coltivano lì nelle condizioni
peggiori e poi la riprenderà
hanno ancora più resistente la
porteranno sempre più in alto sempre più
in alto fino a generare le piante che
noi abbiamo adesso i ceppi di e di cruz
il un coca che vivono a 4.500 metri di
altitudine e che contengono le quantità
migliori di una cocaina purissima ecco
questo è quello che gli agricoltori
hanno fatto da anni mescolar i caratteri
genetici questi sono la contamination
alla cross fertilization che poi è stata
mutuata anche in altri ambiti è stata
adottata questi termini sono stati
adottati per esempio dal business
semplicemente per indicare le nuove
policy aziendali che vogliono portare
nuovi metodi nuove persone nuove
competenze all'interno della stessa
azienda in modo da sviluppare una nuova
generazione di metodologia una nuova
generazione di competenze di professioni
che permettono di sopravvivere meglio di
crescere nella competitività che del
nostro ambiente
ora la contaminazione la cross
fertilization in realtà sono stati il
motore del mondo
il motore della scienza intesa come
conoscenza perché all'inizio tantissimi
millenni fa c'era una sola scienza
pensiamo ai grandi filosofi del passato
pensiamo ad aristotele a parmenide a
socrate che cosa facevano elaboravano
teorie filosofiche sulla vita sulla
morte ma erano anche dei grandi
scienziati erano riusciti a capire che
la natura è fatta di atomi senza avere
le grandi tecnologie che noi abbiamo a
disposizione oggi pensiamo per esempio a
seneca che per primo ipotizzò la natura
fisica del pensiero astratto la natura
fisica delle parole anticipando di
millenni quello che poi poco fanno
dimostrato i neuro biologi e questo è
stato vero sempre nel corso della
scienza pensiamo a leonardo siamo già
nel medioevo leonardo che incarnava
l'uomo artistico l'uomo umanista l'uomo
tecnologico
quindi la scienza si è sempre nutrita di
contaminazione
perché lo scienziato ha sempre cercato
la contaminazione
esercitata perché capiva che era da lì
che veniva l'innovazione e la simply
esercitata per esempio con alcuni
comandamenti che venivano trasmessi da
una generazione all'altra
guarda le cose con occhi nuovi si sa mai
ast liberati da tutti i preconcetti
guarda le cose vedendo come sono e non
cercare di interpretarle come vorresti
la grande rita levi montalcini e lo
diceva sempre nel suo libro elogio
dell'imperfezione dice ai ricercatori di
oggi quando ottieni un dato che non sa
interpretare non tentare di farlo di
inserirlo per forza della tua teoria
mettilo da parte metterlo in un cassetto
e poi ogni tanto vai a guardarlo perché
prima o poi ti dirà qualcosa oppure
grande scienziato vivente jeffrey bar
stock che ho avuto l'onore di avere come
maestro un anglo australiano anche lui
diceva esci dalla tua confor zona sia
anarchico perché non c'è progresso senza
anarchia non c'è progresso se non rompi
dogmi del passato infatti jeff quando
aveva vent'anni a university college
london aveva creato un club un pochino
originale su challenger e sascha lange
sera hanno una serie di ragazzi di
vent'anni chi dubbio noti biologo chi
fisico chi matematico chi storico che
economista che una volta settimana si
radunava university college e decideva
di rompere un dogma e sceglievano una
volta un dogma della matematica una
volta della biologia e lo confutavano
perché sapevano che era solo confutando
i dogmi abbattendo i dogmi del passato
che la scienza può progredire e molti
altri poi dopo l'hanno detto sì veloce e
guarda il mondo guarda tutte le cose
belle che ha fatto l'uomo e poi prendi
quelle cose porta all'interno del tuo
mondo e poi si user centric e cioè non
trasferire semplicemente le tecnologie
da un ambito all'altro ma importa le
persone trasferisci le persone fai
vivere
le persone alle esperienze degli altri e
questo è stato sempre vero per la
scienza
un piccolo esempio ancora il laboratorio
di camillo golgi a pavia nel secolo
scorso
camillo golgi che vinse il nobel perché
per primo riuscì a fotografare i neuroni
sviluppando quella reazione nera che gli
permetteva di vedere i neuroni e tutta
la loro armonizzazione e tutta la loro
ordina organizzazione del cervello
però il suo laboratorio a pavia un
laboratorio dove ogni giorno si faceva
una nuova scoperta non era frequentato
solo da anatomici la physiology da
biologi o da istologi era frequentato da
un teologo da un filosofo come achille
ratti che poi divenne papa era scusate
era frequentato era frequentato quella
non dovrebbe stare dove va bene la
spostiamo dopo era frequentato da
agostino gemelli che poi avrebbe fondato
l'università cattolica del sacro cuore
di milano era frequentato da navigatori
da esploratori da nansen che poi ha
scoperto il circolo polare artico era
frequentato da psichiatri da neurologi
dall'euro biologi perché perché era
proprio da quella contaminazione che
veniva fuori il meglio e ora questo
processo è andato avanti per tanto tempo
fino a pochi decenni fa quando sono
successe alcune cose nuove belle che
però hanno avuto anche degli effetti
collaterali imprevisti che cosa è
successo a partire dagli anni sessanta
abbiamo iniziato a sviluppare un
progresso tecnologico straordinario
abbiamo sviluppato nuovissime tecnologie
che non ci hanno permesso di raffinare
tutti i nostri sistemi di indagine molto
in profondità
faccio un esempio dalla medicina che
quello che vi posso fare meglio abbiamo
sviluppato la cardiologia la pneumologia
la nefrologia a livelli elevatissimi che
ci hanno permesso di risolvere le tante
malattie
però questo altissimo grado di
specializzazione pur avendo dei grandi
vantaggi che cosa prodotto a prodotto
una parcellizzazione del sapere per cui
un medico diventava solo un grande
simo cardiologo un gradissimo nefrologo
un grandissimo epatologo ma a fatica
capiva di tutto il resto e quindi la
mano destra iniziato non sapere più cosa
faceva la sinistra e quindi un radiologo
non riusciva neanche più a parlare con
un epatologo perché non si capivano
quindi dall'altissima grado di
specializzazione dall altissima
tecnologia è purtroppo è derivato la
parcellizzazione del sapere che ha avuto
anche delle conseguenze molto gravi
stando sempre nella medicina a
disumanizzato in parte la medicina
perché il medico iniziato a guardare il
paziente non più in maniera olistica
come aveva fatto fino a quel momento ma
lo guardava come se guardasse un organo
ad un insieme di organi e tanto è vero
che il paziente se n'è accorto e sono
nate sono proliferati una serie di
pseudo scienza non basate in realtà su
fondamenta scientifiche come l'omeopatia
dove però il paziente si riconosceva
perché queste pseudo scienze riportavano
finalmente il paziente al centro
dell'attenzione del medico il paziente
come persona persona non fatta solo gli
organi ma fatta di fisico e di psiche e
quindi ecco che a quel punto alla
medicina si è accorta di questo grande
errore errore che ora dobbiamo rimediare
dobbiamo rimediare per rimettere insieme
tutte le competenze dobbiamo rimediare
anche perché siamo di fronte a
grandissime sfide
abbiamo precisato la scienza abbiamo
avuto un grandissimo sviluppo
tecnologico questo ha prodotto una
grandissima marea di dati in tantissimi
settori differenti
dati che sono una ricchezza
straordinaria enorme prodotta proprio
dall alto grado di specializzazione ma
che ora noi non sappiamo analizzare da
cui ora noi siamo sommersi perché siamo
continuamente esposti a questa marea di
dati che non di cui non sappiamo il
significato sono veramente tanti si sono
veramente tantissimi perché se pensate
che oggi ogni giorno noi creiamo
qualcosa come 2,5 quintilioni di byte di
nuovi dati pensate che il 90 per cento
di tutti i dati
disponibili in questo momento sul globo
sono stati prodotti negli ultimi due
anni e rimanente 10 per cento nei
millenni precedenti quindi capite quello
che sta succedendo è una grandissima
rivoluzione provate a immaginare come
sarà fra qualche anno quando questa
capacità di accumulare dati aumenterà
ancora di più a causa del grandissimo
numero di sensori che noi abbiamo messo
in tutto il mondo perché questi big data
hanno le caratteristiche delle tre vie
vale a dire il valium questo volume così
alto ma anche lavora yeti e la velocity
la variety che cos'è e la fonte di
questi dati che può essere una fonte
persona da persona perché tutte le volte
che noi paghiamo con un amico al
cellulare
usiamo internet o mandiamo un messaggio
di posta elettronica o andiamo sui
social network tra trasferiamo delle
informazioni da persona a persona oppure
la variety consiste nel trasferimento
della persona alla macchina tutte le
volte che usiamo una credi cag una smart
card
tutte le volte che usiamo un device che
comunica qualche nostro dato ad un
sistema oppure da wright e si trasmette
macchina da macchina e quindi il gps e
tutti i dati raccolti da tutti questi
sensori di cui abbiamo invaso il mondo
per fare qualche esempio 2,9 milioni di
mail mandata in un secondo 50 milioni di
twitter mandati nei un giorno ora in
realtà tutte queste informazioni sono
una grandissima ricchezza perché se non
le potessimo analizzare bene se ne
trovassi in un modo per analizzarle
veramente bene conterrebbero la
soluzione a moltissimi problemi
dell'umanità conterebbero delle
informazioni preziosissime per avanzare
per esempio la medicina la telemedicina
vi farò un esempio fra un momento
conterrebbero informazioni per poter
coltivare cibo sulla terra per nutrire
tutte le persone presenti sulla terra e
abbiamo poco abbiamo sentito poco fa
conterrebbero le informazioni necessarie
per sviluppare le telecomunicazioni
marketing di
ogni tipo faccio l'esempio della
telemedicina nella telemedicina tutti i
sensori di cui noi potremmo a nutrire
una smart pausa per controllare e
monitorare attentamente le persone che
ci vivono soprattutto le persone anziane
a cui possiamo arrivare con più
difficoltà che hanno bisogno di
grandissima assistenze bene tutti questi
segnali tutti questi sentori che noi
potremmo analizzarli in remoto ci
permetterebbero di avere dei parametri
in tempo reale dello stato di salute di
queste persone curarle medio prevenire
le malattie diagnosticare ancora prima
che nascano e quindi contrastarle
migliorarle e quindi ottenere un sistema
sanitario più utile più valido per tutti
contenendo dicono la nostra spesa
emergente sanitaria fino al 50 per cento
quindi con un grandissimo risparmio ma
non solo la telemedicina ma tutte le
altre scienze per esempio i cambiamenti
climatici
ora se noi avessimo in già gli abbiamo
sensori sparsi in tutto il mondo che ci
permettono di monitorare la composizione
dei componenti dei gas presenti
nell'aria dei contaminanti del suolo dei
componenti della degli oceani ebbene noi
mettendo insieme tutti questi dati con
degli algoritmi che ci consentissero di
analizzarli veramente bene forse
potremmo capire che cosa si altera che
cambia poi che origina poi il
cambiamento climatico che origina
l'innalzamento della temperatura e
quindi potremmo trovare un modo per
prevenire il cambiamento climatico e
allo stesso modo se noi potessimo
prevenire i terremoti
ora noi sappiamo che i terremoti sono
preceduti da una serie di segnali da una
serie di segnali fisici elettromagnetici
e perfino biologici perché tutti sanno
che gli animali sentono i terremoti
prima che arrivino
quindi se noi potessimo monitorare e
registrare e decodificare tutti questi
segnali con gli algoritmi giusti ecco
che certo non potremmo a prevenire i
terremoti ma potremmo prevederli e
potremo salvare le popolazioni coinvolte
quindi avremo grandissimi vantaggi
analisi di questi dati però però come in
tutte le situazioni
c'è sempre un però ora i nostri colleghi
anglosassoni sono molto intelligenti in
queste dicono ma glik andata e
straordinari d'età
incredible amount of new dei tavoli very
nice web e quando c'è quella however
quel tuttavia quel bat allora iniziano i
problemi
e noi qui abbiamo un grande however il
grande hauer
il grande problema dei big data
l'imperfezione dei dati perché tutti
questi dati raccolti da tutti questi
sensori passi sparsi nel mondo hanno
tante incongruenze hanno tanti valori
mancanti e soprattutto sono formattati
in un modo diverso per cui noi non
riusciamo ad analizzarli perché non
riusciamo a capire il rumore di fondo
dove inizia dove finisce perché non
riusciamo a togliere quel background che
ostacola l'analisi dei dati e quindi ora
ne sappiamo che dobbiamo fare per
poterli analizzare il moon ginga cioè
questa trasformazione dei road età dei
dati proprio crudi in dati omogenei
armonizzati nel formato che possano poi
essere portati al processo ed in
gestione e di analytics ma perché non lo
sappiamo fare proprio perché abbiamo
parcellizzato le scienze e proprio
perché adesso per analizzare tutti
questi dati a fare creare quegli
algoritmi così preziosi abbiamo bisogno
di nuove professioni abbiamo bisogno
particolare del beta scientist che
ancora non esiste che forse inizia
esistere nei paesi anglosassoni è anche
un pochino in europa in germania
forse in francia ma che in italia non
c'è ancora e che è un po l'uomo
leonardiano che abbiamo visto prima vale
a dire un uomo che riassume in sé le
caratteristiche di un artista di uno
scienziato perché deve sapere di
software di statistica deve sapere di
algebra lineare di tecniche metodi di
machine learning ma deve sapere anche di
umanesimo deve sapere di comportamento
perché deve potersi interfacciare in
maniera utile e proficua con tutti gli
altri scienziati coinvolti delle varie
discipline con quei medici quei biologi
quei geologi con i climatologi di cui
parlavamo prima
perché sono solo loro che possono dire
al d'età scientist ha
ecco dove devi settare il background
ecco dove devi settare il rumore di
fondo per poter trovare l'algoritmo
giusto la chiave giusta per leggere quei
dati e poi questo d'età scientist dovrà
anche confrontarsi con altri
professionisti perché noi sappiamo che
stanno emergendo problemi legali legati
per esempio la prove si deve the
problemi informatici legati alla
sicurezza dei dati e alla loro
diffusione e quindi dobbiamo tornare
tutti insieme dobbiamo riunire tutte
quelle competenze che prima avevamo
separato proprio a causa del grande
sviluppo tecnologico
dobbiamo tornare un concerto un concetto
di scienza e di ricerca diffusa
quindi non solo le eccellenze le punte
di eccellenza che fino a questo momento
abbiamo pensato fossero l'unica cosa da
promuovere
come quando sei in un deserto e vedi da
lontano le piramidi e di questi piramidi
vedi solo la punta luccicante in
lontananza luccicante perché è la punta
dorata della piramide tu vedi solo
quella
ma non vedi sotto la piramide fatta di
mattoni di ruvidi mattoni
quella è la scienza la ricerca diffusa
che tutti noi dobbiamo creare
armonizzando i nostri sesso sensori
lavorando insieme integrandoci fra di
noi perché solo facendo così che dalla
scienza diffusa poi si origina
l'eccellenza ed è quella che ci
permetterà di vincere
[Applauso]
[Musica]